good morning hick it's Tuesday so every
November thousands of people around the
world participate in a lovely writing
project called nanor rimo or national
novel writing month wherein they write a
novel in a month and the idea is that if
you just write every day and don't worry
too much about getting it right then you
can write a 50,000-word novel in a month
which is an astonishment to me because
while I have written 2,000 words in a
day I definitely have not been able to
do that 25 days in a row anytime I start
a new writing project I manag to
convince myself it will be quick and
easy like a few years ago when I started
writing about tuberculosis I definitely
thought this is a small and
straightforward project with a limited
audience and no risk of a movie
adaptation it won't be that hard and I
think I was correct about the risk of a
movie adaptation but it has not turned
out to be a a small or straightforward
project because tuberculosis turns out
not to be a small or straightforward
concept and anyway what I'm writing
isn't just about tuberculosis it's also
about how tuberculosis is a form and
expression of Injustice so yeah not only
did I fail to finish that in a month
like here we are 3 years later and I've
still failed to finish it and then a
couple years ago on November 1st I wrote
2,000 words of a new story and again I
thought this is a fairly straightforward
and contained story you know
approximately How It Ends you can do
this uhoh
uh-oh oh no sneezing is never normal but
right on the first day I wrote 2,000
words and I thought if I just do this
for 30 straight days I'll have a 60,000
word novel the problem was that by the
fifth day I was like oh my God there's
so many problems with what I wrote on
the first first day and the second day
and that's just sort of how I write I
write and I write and then I delete and
I delete and I write and I write and
delete and delete and that builds layers
over time that eventually become
something hopefully that I'm happy with
writing and revising are kind of
inextricably linked for me and I don't
really think of them separately because
even the initial Act of writing is a
kind of rewriting for me because I'm
trying to take ideas that exist in sort
of nebulous forms in my head and turn
them into language which is sort of
rewriting you know what I don't want to
harp on this but maybe it wasn't a
sneeze maybe it was a momentary lapse in
judgment but anyway the point is that I
have this wildly inefficient way of
writing and I think I just have to live
with it which is why in 2007 at the dawn
of Vlog Brothers I created an
alternative to nanoro called naat Bim
scom also known as National finisher
draft of your book I mean seriously come
on month and over the years I've been
able to use a few months this way like
in 2010 I completed a draft of my book
The Fault and our stars in mid December
after attempt Naf Bim scom and I
completed a draft of Paper Towns in
November of 2007 during my first ever
Naf Bim scom it occurs to me by the way
that I used to be very open about my
writing process and like where I was in
the writing of a book and then after the
faon Our Stars was published I felt like
I really couldn't do that even on Vlog
brothers because suddenly like there
were lots of people putting lots of
pressure on me and like trying to figure
out like which season a book would come
out in because that had like
implications for a publicly traded
Corporation but now I feel like I can
talk about it I'm trying to finish
something I'm not quite ready to call it
a book but I'm trying to finish
something and that's why I'm trying to
do Naf Fado Bim scom here in November of
2023 uh maybe I should just tell the
truth which is that I've already
finished a draft this is more a naoy
bscom finish a revision of your book I
mean seriously come on month but at any
rate I'm supposed to be writing and so
far it's going terribly because I'm just
a smidge depressed and anxious at the
moment but I'm hoping that by revealing
my plan I can jump start the execution
of it and anyway over the last 20 years
of writing stories one thing that's been
extremely helpful for me is implementing
artificial deadlines and then pretending
that they're real look almost every form
of meaning is constructed right like we
convince ourselves and each other that
this stuff matters because that's how we
get stuff done together and I need to
convince myself that this revision is
due at the end of November 2023 so this
November whether you're doing nanor rimo
or Naf Bim scom or something else that
ends in m I hope that you're able to
complete your deadline and meet your
goals and I hope that I'm able to as
well Hank I'll see you on
Friday the best part of that video was
where you said I'm just a smidge
depressed and anxious but you know what
like uh you like editing video and
you're going to go edit this video and
that will be good
so still recording